hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to go lot
we are currently hiding in a closet not
because we're scared because we don't
want to die and that's not fear talking
that's just cold logic speaking of cold
logic am I going to die alrighty then
Lisa at least it gave me plenty of warm
ok that's just my sister trees a
woodland
don't sound fun it sounds like the
opposite of or does that even give me
like a save point or anything that
seemed like a pretty significant moment
in this game I think just by
happenstance I'm going the right way
I'm gonna drop with that drop kill me
hmm wait okay I do hear the rustling let
me go this way just in case it's up here
because there was another path over this
way so I'm gonna double-check let me
just make sure we're whoa okay ah okay
since so it might actually be up here
hello
anybody seen a page we're also a way not
into the dark forest
okay it must have been down I got go
around I mean I know I know it's
probably not essential to get all the
pages because I'm willing to bet that I
missed one or two here already but just
for the sake of the story I don't want
to miss out on 200
oh god I gotta go back into it I hate
this place it's worse than the one that
was on fire because at least the one on
fire had light oh it's so sucky I can't
see them I can't see them till they're
already like on top of me thought I
thought I thought orange I thought I saw
orange my speech impediment came through
so there's
ah here we go yes yes yes please give me
your demon oh I'm gonna read this later
if they're just gonna creep up behind me
and kill it definitely sounds like the
music of murder okay I'm out of here
okay so if I just keep following this
path over here I think should get me
I think should kill me wait okay I got
it
okay there's a path that like curves
around here to the left so um there
might be something at the end of it I
don't know I haven't checked the
coordinates yet the [ __ ] wouldn't work
okay where was he
I didn't see him okay I don't know where
I am now
I got turned around it's a ham over
there okay
was it
that looks like death okay I reached an
edge of a map
that's all right time oh hey I didn't
notice you there I'm just gonna get out
here I'll come back later if it's
important I'll come back later
obviously they don't want to be
disturbed okay all right so again so
specific
police here it's nothing is a dead end
this is where the drag oh good
markers okay good ah 72 6472 6000k 72 oh
I'm right near it I'm right near where I
might be actually following the path
unless it goes this way which I don't
think good luck was he doing over on the
old look what am i doing
oh god I've jumped back there
Oh God
I'm a racing gotta be conservationist no
I don't think that led anywhere cuz if
this isn't it this is the way out and I
kind of want to follow it
okay there's a page over here that'll
you at least give me an idea where I am
oh damn this game is a blood load of
stress thank you
Mather is pretty good it's a free back
we arranged with the locals that they
will give us a ride to the location of
the second camp we help them unload the
carts and waited for the horses at
approximately 4:00 p.m. we set off to
continue our journey we managed to
replenish food supplies so we could eat
something on our way there great
the horses are moving slowly it's making
me sleepy it's getting dark the second
camp was an abandoned village we found a
house to stay at overnight in total
darkness we started setting up a
fireplace everyone cut themselves on
nails sticking out of the board's apart
from that everything was okay sound
grain then it's all started you mean the
death the abundance of death everywhere
literally everywhere okay I don't know
if I'm safe but I'm gonna try to read
another message hey no not you okay
was it articles nose reports no might
have been diary let me go back a page oh
really
wait what we asked seven eight we see
the wagons what
well that doesn't make any sense I had
oh I set out at the moment no I had
dammit okay okay I got very long the Sun
is just starting to set we are sitting
in seven this must have been a dozen it
was in a report
no I already read that oh I needed to
okay I got okay right here here
anomalies do not exist when almost 20
years ago I wrote about strange anomaly
occurring in my city as a reminder I
brought spatial distortions between the
building that they thought I was nuts
since then man Kanna has been witnessed
to thousands of strange mysterious
unexplained event and phenomena around
the world lot was talking and supported
with hard animus unfortunately did this
day prominent scientists seem not to
notice or simply underestimated you we
have asked dr. Jarvis Northam from the
American University of Technology in
life scientists the novel is appearing
practically around the globe is an
undeniable fact we know that least
several dozen them such events blah blah
blah blah blah blah I'm about to be
murdered
blah blah blah add to that the helpless
attempts to cover up these events 1998
Kremlin officially okay alright okay
okay I don't like that okay all right
where am I
where was it where was that no it was in
the air was it
I hear a slippy slap of some ghosty goos
footprints with ectoplasmic XS if you
know what I mean
okay so if I keep going up this way I
think actually that was not on the trail
that was or maybe it was on the trail I
don't know where I'm going is what I'm
trying to say I really have no idea but
this thing okay good
oh good what huh it was dark it was dark
down there it was dark I saw it was dark
how did that another skull rock this
game don't make no sense or no the game
makes perfect sense what's happening in
this game makes no damn sense all right
anyway sounds cool
that was the forest of death I can't
wait to come back
where are you painting
give me your goodies give me a landmark
cuz for some reason I know exactly where
these are in space and time hello oh we
have never seen such a thing the
activity was off scale energy readings
it was just beyond any reason I remember
dr. P at Nick he said he heard the
singing he saw angels appearing from the
light it was clear to us that it was
dangerous to say too close to the
anomaly for too long
but we had to conduct more tests
therefore we decided to use prisoners
that's why we created section 22 grey
cool
there was this one
so this was right at this bridging path
here so I should just be continuing on
but it shouldn't matter which way I go
but I'm trying to investigate this on
the try to go up and to the right
because that should lead me to where I
need to go and what the hell is this
what are these what the world are these
is someone throwing a party that
remember my birthday oh okay well that's
normal
happens all the time on átwo though okay
I have nothing witty to say it all
anymore not that I'm saying anything
witty for okay I'm gonna run now oh good
stop okay
I am an empty wreck made in His image
but not alike a servant obedient to one
master my body is a shell and I'm ready
to absorb him now I see the plan I see
that magnitude of devastation the
Creator summons me and I want to be his
food
I am humming his chilled I am looking at
the world through his eyes I drink the
blood of his enemies and taste the
rotting bodies I failed a sin sprouting
under my skin I screams in my head I
hear them calling me
I hear the calling of the ones that
through him have already found their
eternal shelter free them my lord free
them and take me instead
fulfill your revenge at the hour of my
death an army of angels comes out from
the orange light their song is made of
one powerful voice I feel their presence
that twisted faces the black eyes
drilling into my consciousness they
demand to finish the work Oh
his presence is overcoming me so poor
and defenseless what have they done to
you
what harm there is a place you were
there as though as I a huge gate and the
Creator hidden behind it only those few
who touched him could understand but you
could you understood and I
you were you talking to bring attire do
you target Anton
Oh what happened they were gone that's
the place that I was
why was up was I not supposed to go
there first I don't know was that orange
mist
oh good insanity has faded away ah the
sky whips to for some reason
cuz I don't think that's normal sighs
it's been oh oh oh it's done now I look
away for one second and you're done
great like a typical man well I can
hardly believe this okay so I did go to
the ultra madness I'm just gonna cross
this little bridge do Danny and I'll be
fine this bridge did that don't work
that's uh it's unworkable it's uh anti
working okay so I just gotta hop across
well I gotta go the long way around
what strange cult happened out here how
did all this get set up who is here like
who is here and was actually able to
survive see that view right there that's
why I want to go into the Siberian
wilderness and just like see the endless
endless like miles and miles or
kilometers and kilometers of endless
like land it's huge
and then you think in the sense of the
entire universe it's not huge like it
really isn't fascinating cause this
impassable damn it
which way am I supposed to go get down
here
that seems like death weight wasn't
really supposed to be able to cross that
bridge because it looks very not
crossable but maybe I do one of those
weirdo jumps again the random ones like
throwing open doors when I least expect
it and jump it across chasms when I
don't understand that I'm able to jump
so maybe that's it maybe I'll try it I
mean obviously I saved right there
because the game saves every time I find
something so maybe this won't kill me
mmm pretty will I just
here we go I'm ready got some weights
let's do this oh all right
okay well that did yeah all right okay
that's okay that's all right daddy
so this caution a psychopath is on the
loose a dangerous criminal has escaped
from the Moscow mental institute we have
been informed the man is completely
insane it is he right behind me
great so that actually it's really
interesting because the magnitude of the
event that I just saw is like was
compounded by the effect of the note
that I read but I think the notes are
being given in order therefore it's
really interesting because like what if
I didn't go there at that point you know
what I mean I need to go 6247 right
there okay so yeah I just need to keep
going alright here we go that's cool you
up there real cool of you oh good Isis
all right whoa that's death holy crap
okay so I think oh is that where I need
to go am I headed towards that next I
might be hopefully there's another note
on the way but I think this is the
correct path oh good I was hoping for
another one of these okay that one's
sticking out branch only hit me right in
the crotch okay though all right I'm
really going up behind the mounds and I
wonder why seriously
kind of reminds me of Skyrim actually if
Skyrim was actually like the
unhospitable
frozen north that people thought it
might be before the expo game came out
okay so this campus right here so then
I'll be oh no I'm right here I'm right
here okay um yeah I'll finish this in
another episode so either why thank you
all so much for watching I hope you're
enjoying this I really am
let me know what you think in the
comments below and let me know if you've
got any other ideas for other cool games
like this that have come out recently
that I haven't seen because this was
released like the week I started playing
it so I caught it right at the beginning
and it's really really cool to see so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
week